oui la contre-offensive craénienne a
démarré depuis plusieurs jours elle a
été préparée avec soin méthode par une
armée des dirigeants qui ont montré
depuis un peu plus d'un an lors
détermination leur bravoure et
l'excellence de leur sens tactique et de
leur organisation oui
[Musique]
l'Ukraine a repris à l'armée russe un
autre village près de Donetsk le
quatrième depuis hier ce serait le fruit
de la contrefensive évoquée du bout des
lèvres samedi par le président volody
mirzeninski après son entretien avec le
Premier ministre Trudeau alors s'agit-il
bel et bien de cette contre-offensive
promise annoncée depuis longtemps comme
le déclare le président de la France
jusqu'à quel point pourrait-elle être
déterminante comme le dit le secrétaire
d'État américain faisant le point avec
Pierre Saint-Cyr il est colonel à la
retraite des Forces armées canadiennes
monsieur Saint-Cyr bonsoir
bonsoir alors il paraît clair pour les
Alliés français et américains que cette
contre-offensive est bel et bien
commencée est-ce que c'est votre opinion
oui elle a été annoncée en plus par le
président zzzleinski le 6 juin dernier
quelle est la contrepensive est en
marche alors c'est une contrefensive qui
est très prudente actuellement on ne
voit pas les grands mouvements comme on
a vu dans le passé dans les autres
guerres je parle dans le département de
Normandie entre autres il y a une asso
est vraiment déterminant ici ce qu'on
voit ce sont des actions qui servent à
organiser le champ de bataille en faveur
des Ukrainiens alors les Ukrainiens vont
faire des petites attaques pour se aller
vérifier la résistance russe ils vont
attaquer en profondeur avec les armes
qu'ils ont les armes de longue portée
qui ont acheté des Américains et des
Anglais pour détruire des postes de
commandement ils vont tenter aussi de
détruire par l'artillerie des défenses
les trois lignes de défenseurs qui sont
installés alors ils vont par petit peu
par petits efforts justement pour
organiser
et trouver aussi les endroits les plus
vulnérables pour les Russes où il
pourrait lancer une plus grande
offensive mais actuellement le français
devient commencer elle est dirigée et
ils sont en train de organiser la
chambre alors ce que je comprends mieux
sont en quelque sorte en train d'ouvrir
des brèches ici et là pour mieux se
positionner pour la grande attaque parce
que c'est ça comme vous avez évoqué le
débarquement de Normandie c'est quand on
pense à contre-offensive on pense à ça
nous profanes qui ne sont pas experts
comme vous donc c'est ça ils ouvrent des
brèches pour mieux se positionner pour
lancer le gros de leur armée plus tard
c'est ça exactement ils vont trouver les
points faibles de la Défense russe pour
exploiter ses points faibles là et faire
des avancées et faire une percée tendez
vous pas vraiment à des grandes
manœuvres comme on a vu je faisais
référence au débarque il va avoir
certaines manœuvres parce que les
Ukrainiens se doivent aussi d'être très
prudent avec leur propre équipements ils
ont eu des équipements des accident ils
veulent protéger ses équipements pour
évidemment efficaces et les langues
soient pas dans les grandes batailles où
il y aura des risques de pertes énormes
alors ils vont y aller dans les actions
chirurgicales pour s'assurer de percer
les défensus de démoraliser les Russes
et aussi de faire des avancées qui pour
éventuellement leur permettre d'aller
plus loin alors les objectifs de l'armée
ukrainienne actuellement c'est pas de
d'aller à la pleine vitesse dans un
blédicri et tout écrasé trop vite à des
défenses russes qui sont déjà bien
établies alors c'est percé au bon
endroit mais dites moi on a vu il y a
une dizaine de jours cette vidéo
ukrainienne ou des soldats Ukrainiens
faisaient chute à la caméra à propos de
cette contre-fensive monsieur Zelinski
bon la tête dit le 16 juin mais en même
temps il parle de Francis défensive
contre-offensive après ça il dit qu'il
pleut en tout cas bref moi j'ai le
sentiment que les ukrainés sont vous
avez dit prudent vous
c'est comme si vous voulez retenir un
petit peu le message dans la
communication est-ce que ça c'est parce
qu'il ne veut pas de les trous d'espoir
aux ukrainiers est-ce que c'est parce
qu'ils veulent cacher des choses Horus
comment vous interprétez ça
je vous dirais que premièrement le
peuple craignait est un peuple résilient
et le moral du peuple ukrainien
actuellement il est très élevé donc je
vous ai inscrit comprend très bien ça il
ne veut pas nécessairement adoucir les
choses pour son propre peuple il est
conscient de la du courage que le peuple
actuellement et la résidence Les Mots de
Monsieur Zelinski où ils laissent planer
des doutes ça fait partie ça fait partie
de l'ordre de la guerre sur Madame on
laisse planer des doutes autant envers
l'ennemi alors l'ennemi n'est pas sûr
est-ce qu'il s'en vient est-ce que ça
son plein foncés sur nous comment qu'on
se prépare alors c'est un jeu
psychologique qui se fait autant envers
l'adversaire de ne pas être précis
les actions m'ont parlé des autres même
alors ce qui arrive actuellement c'est
que dans cette préparation là dans cette
organisation là les Russes eux ont fait
trois lignes de défense avec des
barrages et toutes sortes d'obstacles
de béton là exactement
je dirais une profondeur de 20 km à
l'intérieur de leur ligne actuellement
mais ce qu'ils ont fait aussi c'est
qu'ils ont réduit la mobilité des armées
ukrainiennes en détruisant les barrages
en inondant certains territoires qui
fait que la mobilité dans ce secteur-là
devient difficile alors de leur côté les
Russes tentent tant bien que mal de
interdire certains accès et laisser
moins de corridors aux forces
ukrainiennes pour pénétrer l'envers les
défenses russes alors il y a une
production et une contreproduction quand
on production d'avoir des Russes et la
production pour organiser des terrains
de bataille de la part des
Ukrainiens alors la chute de ces quatre
villages ou cette reprise de ces quatre
villages Ukrainiens on met des Russes là
dont annoncer par le gouvernement
ukrainien ce sont de des victoires
importantes
non non ce sont des ce sont des
victoires quand même relativement
important pour eux mais c'est pas des
victoires stratégiques c'est des
objectifs à court terme ce que ça fait
c'est que ça vaut 50
ils se font défaire les
résistance n'est pas assez forte pour
arrêter du grenier c'est exactement le
but de la manœuvre des ukraines c'est
savoir où aller et où percer dans les
points les plus vulnérables alors il y a
des de selon ce qu'on lit il y a des
soldats qui défendent c'est le
territoire il y en a plusieurs qui
quittent qui s'éloigne qui qui ne font
pas face à l'ennemi et abandonne la
chambre bazar donc il y a déjà un effet
sur le moral les soldats russes
actuellement alors donc ce que si je
vous suis bien
si cette en ce moment ce qui se passe
c'est d'ouvrir des brèches pour que le
gros de l'armée ukrainienne finissent
par passer donc on peut s'attendre à une
intensification des combats il y a des
choses de beaucoup plus grandes
envergure dans quoi un mois deux mois
moins que ça
le temps on sait pas Madame tout ce que
tout va dépendre de la façon que les
brèches sont ouvertes la façon qu'ils
vont exploiter ces gains là sur le
terrain ça peut être dépendant si la
résistance est très faible une offensive
un petit peu plus rapide dans ce
secteur-là et tout dépend est-ce qu'on
sait pas encore ce qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est toujours les objectifs
stratégiques derrière ça qu'est-ce que
les Ukrainiens veulent vraiment faire
est-ce qu'ils veulent se rendre jusqu'à
la frontière de la Russie est-ce qu'il
veut d'avoir des succès importants comme
la reprise de ville comme Melito Paul
comme Mario Paul s'assurer de contrôler
de part entière la centrale nucléaire de
saporégia alors quels sont les
véritables objectifs stratégiques
c'est ce secret ces choses dans le site
alors tout dépend de ces stratégique
leurs actions sur le terrain vont
découler de ça alors c'est comme ça que
vous et moi pourriez en faire pour la
fin de l'entrevue merci beaucoup
monsieur Sancy
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI